depuis le 22 août la sncf a mis en place
de nouveaux horaires sur la ligne
reliant mantes-la-jolie à paris
montparnasse ou encore rambouillet des
modifications contestée par la ville de
saint cyr l'école j'ai aussi un terrain
était interpellé par des gens qui
s'étonnait de ne pas retrouver alors
qu'il retournait le travail en
présentiel le train qu'ils avaient
l'habitude de prendre est donc très
clairement on a un enjeu parce qu'on a
des parents qui déposent leurs enfants à
l'école ou à la crèche est qui et qui
prennent un train dans le quart d'heure
qui suit pour aller à l'heure au travail
là aujourd'hui on leur dit que ce train
ne circule plus et qu'il faut partir à
un quart d'heure plus tard ou un quart
d'heure plus tôt
le temps de parcours des yvelinois sur
la ligne n s'est allongée de quatre
minutes provoquant des soucis au niveau
de leur correspondance avec d'autres
trains ou bus à sharp en veut pas on ne
laisse pas sa correspondance et puis on
aimerait bien que les aides avant
qu'enfin nous reviennent pour l'élu au
transport et à la circulation en retour
aux anciens horaires est nécessaire dès
ce 12 décembre ce qu'on attend à saint
cyr l'école c'est que dès le changement
de service donc le 12 décembre prochain
on revienne à minima à la fréquence
qu'on connaissait sur l union n avant qu
vide c'est-à-dire un train tous les
quarts d'heure toute la semaine donc un
train par demi-heure sur les axes et
qu'on revienne aux heures de pointe au
schéma de desserte qu'on avait avant
c'est à dire d'être un semis direct
entre sèvres et paris montparnasse pour
les branches de plaisir grignon et
mantes la jolie et semis direct entre
viroflay paris montparnasse pour les
branches de rambouillet pour permettre
aux gens de ne pas avoir un allongement
du temps de parcours qui est très
préjudiciable à la qualité de vie la
ville de saint cyr l'école espère ainsi
pouvoir compter sur l'appui des autres
commune yvelinoise desservi par la ligne
n